Right now, young women are really putting their foot down and saying,
"These are our bodies, so we don't really care what you,
you know, 45 year old mom in the suburbs, think is consent.
And we don't care what you, 55 year old college president, think is consent.
These are our bodies, and this is what we say."
From the conviction of Vanderbilt University football players for raping an unconscious student
to the he said, she said story behind Columbia University's mattress girl,
to the discredited Rolling Stones story about a gang rape at the University of Virginia,
few topics generate more emotion and outrage, than sexual assault on college campuses.
Vanessa Grigoriadis is a National Magazine Award winning journalist
and the author of the new book 'Blurred Lines: Rethinking Sex, Power, & Consent on Campus.'
"Millenial college students are actually having less sex than their baby boomer counterparts did"
writes Grigoriadis
"But today's encounters take place in a hyper sexualized and pornified social media context
that has rewritten the rules of consent and privacy."
"The result is confusion and recriminations from all sides when it comes to sex and assault on campuses."
Are assault rates and rape culture out of control?
Or have we entered what left-wing Northwestern professor Laura Kipnis has called
'A new era of sexual McCarthyism.'
I talked to Grigoriadis about all this and more in Reason's New York studio.